on prime crime
a frightening call starts a haunting
story
where i had to just like grab her and i
just would
lean forward and just press the police
interviews that are still
hard to believe my violin starts with
live start
and the pain behind it all were you
sexually assaulted
several times in every way imaginable
[Music]
hey there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile and memorable
true crime cases anytime we focus on a
serial killer we're talking about the
worst
of the worst and this story is just that
hi everyone what is to your emergency
street laundry mat
[Music]
dude 9-1-1 dispatchers receive all kinds
of calls
but the one placed on september 13 2016
in ashland ohio
is not one you hear every day
a woman says that she's been kidnapped
and it soon becomes clear
why she's whispering where's he at now
asleep i'm in the bedroom with them
is there any way you can get out of the
building i don't know without leaking
him and i'm scared
does he have a weapon he's got a taser
are you tied up now
that was horrifying whatever reason
you know she just didn't tie it tight
enough i think it's like a one in a
million that she was able to not only
get out of the rope but have access to a
phone
and then be able to even make the phone
call
do you think you can get out you need to
get out it's not unless you were right
here
a long silence follows for several
minutes luckily the caller
gets back on the phone are you still
there
officers arrive on the scene
where is he
but who was this attacker who abducted
you
sean great sean
michael great a convicted felon who
spent time behind bars
and had been arrested multiple times for
offenses ranging from domestic violence
related crimes
to burglary what we know is that he has
a history since he was a young child he
was described as just
staring at people he has been violent
since a very young age violence towards
women
and this has just escalated over time
later that day
sean great is brought into an
interrogation room a shirtless great
decides to speak with ashland police
captain david lay
what you're about to hear is the start
of something
truly disturbing
well it ended up she didn't like it
really beating herself up about it
so it looks like you might have heard a
couple times
i did because i lost control
great would explain to lay that he
befriended jane doe at a community
center
brought her back to a place where he'd
been squatting and then kept her for
days
all while assaulting her why did you
lose control
[Music]
and marry me um won't marry me you know
a lot of leading me she may not have
wanted to have sex
late afterwards after what
after i hit her the traits that i'm
seeing are pretty indicative
of antisocial personality disorder which
is
having poor impulse control wanting to
be intimidating
lack of remorse lack of empathy but what
we also see
is some sexual sadism she's saying you
tied her
down to a bed i mean what's to do with
all the straps on the mattresses
i did tire down and abducted her
you abduct her yeah the person gains
pleasure
from the pain of others so binding them
torturing them
keeping them hostage she says you took
some
video of her when you forced her to give
her give you oral sex
from your cell phone yeah
the combined anti-social personality
disorder with sexual sadism is
incredibly dangerous
and also nearly impossible to treat
but the conversation with lei takes a
different turn
now troll guys are saying you know
elizabeth
elizabeth griffith was a 29 year old
schizophrenic
who disappeared the month before she's
missing
that's what i heard how'd you hear that
kind of makes me wonder if you didn't
have something to do with her
[Music]
coming up next does great have the
answers on elizabeth's whereabouts
um i know maybe she's better off though
[Music]
back in 2016 sean great is arrested in
ohio
after a woman he had been holding
captive escapes and calls 9-1-1
to investigate her surprise great admits
to beating
and sexually assaulting this jane doe
where'd you grab her
now ashland police captain david lay
suspects that great may also be involved
in the disappearance of another woman
elizabeth griffith who went missing a
month earlier
great initially says he doesn't know
anything about it
but then he says this where's she at
she's no more problems
yet he clams up again then detective kim
majors brought in to question great
i'm looking for elizabeth's body
she's dead i believe she is
this is your moment is it my moment
and finally he breaks
where i came from yeah there's somebody
in there
how is it is it elizabeth
where is she in there in the closet
according to great on the day in
question he and griffith played yahtzee
and then later that night she came over
to the house where he had been staying
he claims griffith was suicidal and that
he tried to strangle her as a way to
playfully scare her
a scare he says turned deadly
let's see exactly how much they really
do want to adapt
you know i mean something a little
feeling all right yeah
she fought it like that's not what you
want and then she like just started
blowing up like
you strangle her again is that how she
died or is there another way
that's the way griffith's naked
decomposed and bound corpse would be
found under a pile of clothes in the
closet of the house
the horrors didn't end there are there
any other
girls in the house right now
yeah one
down in the basement she just led me on
to the point of there was no stopping
and
really irritated me i don't know
through everything else i just stamped
him what's her name
stacy police now also discovered the
dead body of 43 year old stacy hicks
also known as stacy stanley in the house
as well
a mother and grandmother who great met
outside a gas station
after helping to change her flat tire
authorities say he lured her back to the
house
where he sexually assaulted her and
violently choked her to death
did she try to fight you when you were
strangling her
yeah i
made her actually get me i was in that
rage i was like
all right great even agrees to
demonstrate on a detective
how he killed elizabeth and stacy
elizabeth right it's kind of shocking
right i was just joking
we were just joking like how she wished
she kind of
would die you know man i was like so so
i'll help you i just feel like this you
know i mean
like i should forward and love it the
same time right
and she kind of just like whacked my
hands
like started flipping out and stuff like
that to the point
where i had to just like grab her and i
just would
lean forward and just press with
strangling you're looking
at power and control the ability to
watch somebody up close see what happens
to their eyes and watch them
take their last breath it is indicative
that he
enjoys the control that he has over
people
i'm still thinking about this a lot went
wrong
exactly with stacy like she struggled
she did turn around there's a timeline
i just squeezed her neck put all my
weight in the arm for a moment like that
i just clenched lean back
[Music]
as great explains these details to law
enforcement you have to wonder
why is he saying all this i think that
once he had gotten
caught he knew that he couldn't kill
anymore
and he enjoyed this control and
manipulation that he had and so this was
one way that he could
keep that going you may think sean great
has told investigators everything
but they're about to be shocked once
again
stay with us
[Music]
i've shocked a lot of people
you have yeah in 2016
ohio police are investigating sean great
he was arrested after a woman he had
kidnapped untied herself and called
9-1-1
authorities discovered the dead bodies
of two other women in the house were
graded been staying
elizabeth griffith and stacy stanley as
of now
grade has only been linked to three
victims but that's
about to change four
four one four women which one am i
missing
candace cunningham a 29 year old woman
that great had been living with
until ultimately killing her too i
grabbed her and that's when i choked her
she passed out i was irritable
i had enough i just finished her grate
would not only confess to her murder
but he even went on a ride along with
police to lead them to her body
which he discarded next to a burned down
house
across the creek she was pretty alive
yeah seems like though wow
[Music]
great didn't stop there there's a case
from
out in the county meaning
that we found a girl rebecca lacy
yes sir i had problems with her at once
when 31 year old rebecca lacy was found
dead the coroner originally ruled her
death an overdose
however great says he was the one who
killed her
yeah rebecca is number two okay
pretty much self-defense on that one
she brought me out just napped like she
just knew i don't know
finally greg comes full circle and
admits to the 2006 cold case murder
of 23 year old magazine saleswoman dana
lowry
his very first known victim great picked
up dana after
apparently being enraged that she failed
to deliver subscriptions
to his mother's house grabbed her like
she just
was meant to be choked up this one
first thing i did when i went downstairs
stabbed her in my neck i didn't know
what to do
well not only is he a serial killer but
he's a sexual sadist
and a power and control type of serial
killer and what we see
is that he escalates over time probably
because
the high just isn't as good as it used
to be
what motivated great though to kill
these women
you know he has these reasons one of
them he claimed stole money from him
another woman you know was selling
subscriptions and he said she was lying
the first two were more thieves
one of them he said was so depressed he
was kind of giving her a chance to
realize she wanted to be alive i'm not
going to marry her
and i don't see no one else marrying her
she's going to be miserable or alive
there was this sense that like they had
wronged him in some way
that there was some justification in his
mind that
they kind of maybe deserved it in some
way
my violence starts with live start
candace was a province i just
tortured her for about three days
coming up next we learn exactly what
happened in that dilapidated house
with both hands around my neck was he
facing
i think all court shows are the same
we're talking about your father
guilty or not guilty guilty think again
judge caprio rules with common sense i
was having contractions i was rushing to
the hospital
inspector quinn what does justice demand
jail
and compassion i'm going to take the
circumstances into consideration
the best court experience i've had
clearly judge he's been in a court
before
get caught in providence
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
welcome to prime crime tonight another
day of drama between both sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the law and crime network is everywhere
and we invite
you inside the jury box this
is law and crime
[Music]
brought these women into my life somehow
for a reason but
the thinking i'm learning that it wasn't
really god it was the devil by 2018
sean great was linked to the murders of
five women primarily from his own
recorded confessions
in his first trial he faced charges in
connection with the deaths of elizabeth
griffith and stacy stanley
as well as the kidnapping of a third
woman who was able to escape from his
clutches
and call 9-1-1 it was her testimony
that left everyone speechless i remember
him asking
if i had an extra bible according to
this victim referred to as
jane doe great had struck up a
friendship with her and expressed that
he had a shared interest in religion
you know he always came off as a nice
guy
yet on the night of september 11 2016 he
convinced her to come back to the
abandoned house he had been staying
once there things took a terrifying turn
so when he started pulling the bible
from my hands
i just looked up like curious like what
are you doing
and um that's when he said
that's when he says you're not going
anywhere
we started fighting i was just doing
everything um
trying to kick punch but everything i
did
he just did it so much harder and did
you continue
until he started choking me
i stopped because i knew
i couldn't get out of it it gets even
worse were you sexually assaulted
several times
[Music]
in every way imaginable she was able to
give an accounting of what it was like
being with him
it gives us a window into what it was
like for the other victims
although we've already heard the 911
call of her escape
now we're about to really understand
what was going on in the background
i sat up and he was still asleep
i think i was working on trying to get
unbound
but i was really frightened because the
first night he was very alert
and then i sat back up and
i reached over him trying to
get the phone that was going off every
five minutes
remember that brief moment of panic on
the call
i accidentally hit the taser
and uh and the crackling is loud and it
woke him up
and he sat up he put his feet down on
the floor he's just really groggy though
he just looked at the floor
like he was still asleep or out of it
he just sat like that it seemed like 30
seconds
and then he laid back down that's how
close she came to possibly never getting
out of there alive
he is an experienced killer at this
point
it's amazing that he didn't wake up and
didn't stop her
but you know honestly like thank
goodness he was gonna
keep killing women she saved so many
lives
by the end of the trial grate pled
guilty to 15 of the 23 charges
and the jury convicted great of the
remaining counts
now they had to determine whether to
sentence him to death
he says that the thing that scares him
the most
is being put to death by the state i
really
would like to stay alive through all
this yes
i imagine he tried to get a plea deal
that would have taken capital punishment
off the table
and wasn't able to do that one agrees we
the jury team julian panel
unanimously find that the sense of death
should be imposed upon sean and grace
this is dated the following year while
behind bars
great pled guilty to the murders of
rebecca lacy candice cunningham and dana
lowry
with him receiving separate terms of
life in prison
there's an interesting wrinkle though
great's been fighting his death sentence
in the ashland case
the ohio supreme court has upheld his
conviction and penalty
so the court found that although there
were definitely instances where his
council was ineffective they didn't even
raise
basic objections the court said the
amount of
evidence against him was so overwhelming
he still would have been convicted
but at the time of this taping the
supreme court has allowed the
appointment of a new attorney for grade
he doesn't want to get killed by this
state
this helps delay that even if at the end
of the day
after exhausting all the appeals he's
still convicted
we're talking about years of a delay and
at that point
ohio may decide not to ever
use the death penalty time will tell
what happens to sean great
but here's something to remember when
thinking about him ever getting a second
chance
i would have loved been able to do a lot
but i know i wouldn't be able to get
away with it
when you think about what sean great did
he really is the epitome of evil
the only positive in all this is that he
was caught before he could do even more
harm
because of the brave actions of one of
his victims and based on the ohio
supreme court's decision
sean great is hopefully going to stay
where he belongs
that's all we have for you here on prime
crime leave us your comments on twitter
and instagram with the hashtag
primecrime
as always thank you for joining us and
until next time
be safe
[Music]
so
you